named Dave for continued it's 816 I'm
back from work the lane post this
morning I'm sorry about that I was very
tired it was lame there's not a whole
lot to report right now oh my friend is
moving in tomorrow Michelle she will be
making a cameo appearance that is
permanent for the rest of my stay she's
moving in tomorrow night and I didn't
tell them that she was gonna be living
with me for the month but they're gonna
know because the neighbors are outside
all the time
all the [ __ ] time there are two kids
but it's cold and kids should be inside
anyway they they're gonna know cuz
they're gonna see her coming into the
house and leaving the house and they're
gonna think that we're lesbians which I
didn't think of until now but she was a
dog owner so I figured doesn't matter
plus I've already done tons of terrible
[ __ ] in this house and I'm sure that
they have some sort of system of hidden
cameras excuse me
that is gross I'm excited for her to
move in and they'll be like permanent
girls sleepover but cool adult hanging
out time so you will be seeing surprise
mystery guest tomorrow or the duration
of the month on this vlog